Hello Freak bitches.
We don't want you outrageous.
Like I want a viper.
You can't try that hyper.
Not Hyper.
What's an American car?
Can you ever have a vapor can imagine drove a viper and a Ford 158 corvette
convertible.
Fucking big Elvis sunglasses.
Yeah,
I'm free.
You fucks.
If it was me and I finished up,
I would drive away from the White House in my last day in an El Camino.
It's just,
this is the fact that drives my wife crazy.
I,
I've always,
always wanted an El Camino.
I've always kept my alf or,
you know what,
you give me an El Camino come every year.
Uh,
it was manufactured and I would be a happy boy because I don't know why.
And it's,
it's,
it's irrational.
And my wife hates it because she thinks it's a,
it's a horrible looking car.
Do you have one?
I don't.
I've got my latest one.
My latest by was a,
as a,
a wagon here.
Remember the old jeep wagon?
He with a wood panel on the side I bought,
I bought one of those and it's uh,
it's uh,
actually being redone at,
at bucks four by four and in Idaho for all your,
all your automotive needs.
So you bought it and you're refurbishing it or is it the last year they
manufactured it?
91 91.
And it's got an original Shag carpeting in there and it's uh,
it's just uh,
it's a brilliant vehicle.
Got The big bench seat.
Remember the bench seat you'd have and CDC,
those are good when you went around corners just slid all over them depending on
if you had to girl by your side,
then you know,
you take the hard left turn.
Oh,
what do you mean over here?
That was big seats.
Yeah.
Almost like that.
Huh?
I ain't even one car.
That's a piece of shit that is not to say that.
Look at that son of a bitch.
That's a fucking ugly cat is a car right there.
And you know what that thing weighs about 400,000 tons.
This solid steel.
I tap.
What the fuck that I know of.
That one is a tap that's been,
yeah,
that's
weird.
Yeah.
That shouldn't happen.
You want it classic.
You want a classic test,
right?
You keep it classic and like the wood panel.
Oh,
are you kidding me?
Of course.
How could you see that's validated?
All the common sense that you've laid out on this podcast.
There's a lot of people out there that would look at the Woodside wagon here and
say,
yeah,
I get it.
That's a great vehicle.
There's a Camino.
To be fair.
A lot more throwing up in their mouth.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
thank you for that fucking keyboards.
This is essentially,
so it's sort of a preview of the,
this weekend's fights are really just a chance to get together and fuck around.
I was told it was a breakdown,
but he couldn't be.
I was told to break down hair.
I've studied all night for a break.
I have my notes.
I was told this is a breakdown.
What are your thoughts,
sir?
I'm glad you asked.
I'm going to go with a asked me,
asked me.
Well,
I'm going to go with Nate Diaz now.
Ask me why.
Wow.
Well,
the way I look at it,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
Connors boxed the daylights at everybody.
Who for the most part either has his reach or smallest way does he hangs on the
edge of the pocket.
He hangs on the edge of the pocket and he's a counterpuncher waits to you commit
slips and hits.
He's dealing with something very different with Nate,
which is that Nate is longer and taller and neat,
doesn't have to do that.
And I wonder what he's going to have to do is either one of two things is going
to have to weave and get inside or because nightstands so you know,
flat,
I mean it's sort of squares up with you.
I guess he could back kick in front kick is his body,
but kind doesn't kick.
Like it's not what you think.
Whoa.
Watch out for Connor.
Connor's a hard kicks.
You know what I mean?
So he actually keeps pretty good.
Yeah,
he does.
Very good kid.
He doesn't,
I haven't seen much of him cause he's smoking.
Everyone is murky.
But Nate's a very durable guy too.
He spends a lot of time in those gyms with a lot of those Mexican boxers that
stand in the hole and just bang,
which is in Connor.
It's not,
but I,
I wonder how common is going to actually have to change a little bit of his
boxing and I'm curious to see how he does it.
He's only um,
what about this idea?
What if,
what if Meisha Tate crawled on about a three point stance.
Literally crawled toward Holly home cause she couldn't get kicked Sean Jones
style.
Right.
And just grabbed her ankle.
Picked single does.
She won't be going to punch her.
She's in a punch in the face.
I kicked her arms but oh my God,
that's not a viable,
let's see.
Get them kicks show.
She can kick the shit out of those arms.
Let me tell you something to do to have you on all forms,
on all fours and someone kicks your arms.
Horrific.
Break your arm and your dumb ass as they get up and fight with one [inaudible]
guys.
Sorry.
It was my,
my status.
She's probably listening me.
Shit.
Don't do that.
It's bad.
I should a climbed on top of the Octagon and leaped to the center of the Misha
has a knife.
Guys.
You ever thought about that do well,
you can't do that if Nisha knows named Jitsu,
right?
What does she a golf,
sleeping dust.
I need to stand hopes calling.
Put Him on speaker.
Stan,
hope you're on Rogan's podcast.
You're on speaker
delay.
He
notices his fucking phone vibrating in his pocket.
No,
it doesn't delay Killam volume.
We'll pause it.
You pause it.
Can we pause the show?
No,
no,
no.
He's talking to just stand still.
Stand.
Still.
Pause.
I texted Rogan a picture of you in the fun house.
Yeah.
I just got it.
Here it is.
Is this me hammer?
Yeah.
I just texted a picture of us.
Oh Shit.
You in the fun house.
What's going on?
Yeah,
we,
we came in late.
Chad shank said he's been watching it since the beginning.
He goes,
they mentioned my name.
He can't hear us.
Yeah.
Well you can tell it's beer,
but here.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Do you hear us,
Doug?
It's on speakerphone and he should be able to hear us using speaker phone.
Yeah.
Oh,
he's watching.
Oh yeah.
Hang on.
Shit.
No wait,
we pause.
Do you
see or talk to Joe?
Did you just do it?
Well,
I'm just saying you're the only one who could talk to him.
Douglas.
Yeah,
sure.
We have a,
we have a shitty way of communicating here.
We've got to figure out a better way to do this because you could only hear us
when we're like really close to this phone.
You're not wired into anything,
so we have to pass the phone around for you to hear us.
Unless you like this speaker phone works pretty well.
I was just trying to fuck with Chrysler.
I think you need colleagues for good to turn his phone off for the plug.
Dawn.
Doug.
No,
nobody ever turns it off.
They turn it over.
We're too addicted to turn it off.
Nobody.
Nobody turned shit off.
It's too,
you never know.
Someone might get in contact with you.
What the fuck's going on in the desert sun?
Ah,
that we,
uh,
we,
we did date.
You have bingos disappearance.
I Dunno.
Burk talked about that in early.
Yeah,
he did.
Yeah.
The gate two,
at the end of it,
she calls and uh,
reveals her location.
Whoa.
So got it.
Ain't over there.
Still has to be the,
uh,
what's it gonna be?
Is it going to be him or is it going to be me?
Whoa.
No gunfight.
Don't do that.
No,
no,
no.
You're cool.
So you and the guy.
Cool.
Um,
so,
so you're hopeful that it's all gonna work out.
It'll work out one way or the other.
I just hope it works out in my favor.
Well,
we agree,
right?
Well,
go back to your plan.
Yeah.
We're going to go back to the podcast.
All right,
brother.
Have fun out there.
I love you too,
buddy.
See Ya.
All right,
Ruby.
Okay.
Hey,
uh,
the,
everyone check,
it's Doug scan hope.
Don't be scared to tell your friends you love them.
Now everybody's,
I love you to Doug.
When I said goodbye,
I liked it.
I love you to everybody.
I like Doug sold his podcasts and coming up at the very end,
we find out what Bingo did and where she is.
You could check it out on iTunes podcast.
His podcast is so fucking good.
[inaudible]
yeah.